i don't think i i don't i still don't
think i am conservative in the older
meaning of the word um i'm definitely
not
you know if you went and read some
particular
you know political treatise on
conservatism i'm going to disagree with
quite a bit of it
at the same time i find a lot of
sympathy for
the arguments of preserving something
that is worth
preserving or conserving that so yeah i
was definitely not a radical definitely
kind of
middle of the road average every day
liberal left kind of guy and
i was i was genuinely like you said
apprehensive it is a kind of an
understatement to work with
conservatives in a significant
regard which has been really an
interesting experience because
they're exactly the opposite of what the
leftist propaganda had told me they
would be like
so to get to where we started for a
second when i said to you oh you're
going to find common cause with some of
the conservatives and it's going to be a
little scary and all that
can you just tell people because i think
for people that maybe only know some
ancillary little thing about you
you well i don't want to put any words
in your mouth but you were sort of you
used to be just
like sort of a nominal liberal something
like that like you're not
you're not a political radical in any
way that's the irony
yeah i'm i'm not in fact i still
describe myself on twitter
to many people's chagrin so it's a
little troll going on there too
as apolitical i don't actually find
politics that interesting i mean i don't
really care
what joe biden's up to i just don't find
like oh democrats said this republicans
i don't find it interesting
so in that regard i really am apolitical
i definitely
you know kind of morally and politic
like policy-wise
and tilted to the left i'm largely
not in like the the strict sense that
you would see
from the libertarian party but i'm
largely libertarian i just want people
to do what they want to do
leave people alone for the most part and
let's try to organize a society that
kind of works
around that as a basic principle and so
i've never really been
terribly radical i did lean left for
sure
and i was always a little bit annoyed um
with conservatism overall i don't think
i
i don't i still don't think i am
conservative in the older
meaning of the word um i'm definitely
not
you know if you went and read some
particular
you know political treatise on
conservatism i'm going to disagree with
quite a bit of it
at the same time i find a lot of
sympathy for
the arguments of preserving something
that is worth
preserving or conserving that so yeah i
was definitely not a radical definitely
kind of
middle of the road average every day
liberal left kind of guy and
i was i was genuinely like you said
apprehensive it's a kind of an
understatement to work with
conservatives in a significant
regard um which has been really an
interesting experience because
they're exactly the opposite of what the
leftist propaganda had told me they
would be like
all right okay so so let's do that then
because
flash forward a couple years and
suddenly i believe it was
last december so december 2020 it was
the one
speaking gig i did in all of 2020 public
speaking at least in front of a crowd i
probably
same for you i bumped into you at
turning point usa
uh this is obviously charlie kirk's
event it's it's a
in essence a well it's a conservative
uh movement obviously but it's very
linked to well-known republicans and all
that
and that's where i was like ah james
look at this look at you
two three years later what what have you
found
as you've talked about critical race
theory as you've exposed this stuff
what have you found each side has sort
of shown you
well the left is either
delusional about what's going on or
lying there's
no other way to put it they they claim
that people haven't the people that
criticize critical race theory for
example haven't read it
so that's the new thing as we're taping
this today it's the number one trend on
twitter right now
and it's because people like joy reid
from msnbc are saying
nobody even that criticizes uh crt
even has any understanding of what it is
that seems to be the big move even
though i'm seeing plenty of people
explain it over and over again
yeah i don't think they've read it or if
they have read it they've read it with
kind of these rose-colored glasses or
without an understanding of what the
specialized language
actually means you know you order you
read a word like democracy and you think
it means something oh i know what
democracy means
but if you don't understand that in a
liberationist paradigm that it's not
possible to have a true democracy till
everybody is equal in other words until
communism is achieved
it's a loaded word so they don't
understand that a lot of the words
in these things are loaded and they were
intentionally loaded the right however
has been a bit um
facile and its analysis of critical race
theory so it's been very helpful
you know or very good for me to be able
to help them understand it at a deeper
level because for them they've just been
saying socialism and
while that's some percentage truth
20 something maybe percent i don't know
how to qualify those things
it's not the whole story it's not the
whole story by any stretch
and they have however been very
receptive to trying to understand
more about it they've been very curious
about it they perceive that something is
wrong and
and don't have the vocabulary to
comprehend what that is whereas what i
perceive
from people on the left is that they
don't want the vocabulary to comprehend
it it's almost like they want their head
if they're good decent everyday liberals
not activists it's like they want their
head
in the sand to not comprehend what's
going on
and so they constantly get blindsided
it's like i watch some of these people
on twitter the kind of
you know left country club very smart
people i call them uh it's like watching
them step on a rake
over and over and over again it's like
whacks them in the face and they're like
you know
why are these rakes here whack and they
do it again and it whacks them in the
face and like everybody should be nicer
whack and it hits them in the face again
i think it's very important
it's it is it's really it's really
horrific um
so i feel like there's this very deep
you know desire to learn more
and get it accurate among most
conservatives whereas others are just
kind of like
no it's socialism the end and then on
the left there's just straight
either delusional ignorance or lying
about it which is
shocking has that changed your feelings
on
what a liberal is in a way because to me
it exposed a fatal flaw in liberalism
that i did not want to see
it doesn't change for me what a liberal
is in the kind of classical
philosophical liberal sense what it
changes for me is people who identify
as the liberal label have they're
largely a country club they are largely
almost
at this point a cult that want to
believe and have a social identity
baked into being left of center
to where upholding that social identity
becomes much more important than the
truth so when you talk about actual
classical liberalism
based on enlightenment rationalism the
truth is supposed to be the north star
for almost everything and so they have
diverged and it literally is a country
club mentality or a social identity
mentality
that has captured an enormous swath of
that population to the point where it's
like i've had conversations with family
members
and they say things like oh well i
really like what that ron desantis says
but he's a republican so i could never
vote for him
and is that's the entirety of the
analysis is that they don't want to look
bad to their oh this is we only ever
vote democrat friends
or whatever and it's that is disgusting
that's something i never would have
identified with or
respected even in somebody even several
years ago when we were
having that conversation right well and
it's and it's anti-liberal
it's anti-lock it's anti-reason right
that's the point so
so as you then were talking about this
publicly then you start getting invited
to these turning point things and
on to other uh let's say conservative
leaning shows
and then you go on and you i've been
i've watched enough interviews you talk
about being an atheist you talk about
some of the differences you have
as you're unpacking all the crt stuff
and it seems to me nobody cares
which is very much my experience no i
actually end up having really
interesting conversations with people
who want to learn more about my
perspective
if i were trying to be subversive which
i have no real interest in doing
but it's much more effective to be
making friends and coming in in good
faith rather than just attacking because
they actually want to hear my
perspective oh i'll think about that
rather than you know
shut up libtard you know it's been a
very different experience i've had
nothing but a very welcoming friendly
kind
interested experience as i go along
because i'm trying to offer them
something that is of value to
speaking vocabulary into their
experience that they
they know something's wrong they don't
know what and i found nothing but
acceptance actually i mean what
a big red pill experience for me i went
to cpac in 2020 you know
so obviously let me get my devil horns
out but i went to cpac and i didn't know
what to expect i didn't really want to
go but i was in dc
and i thought you know let's pop over
for a day
see what's going i went one day just for
the afternoon i didn't make a big deal
of it i wasn't part of the conference
just wanted to walk around and see and i
expected you know i was gonna walk it
from leftist indoctrination
i expected i was gonna walk into like
the whitest room in the world and all of
you know all of these things that
they've said and it
wasn't that and before that i went to
this big conservative
uh christian conference and i expect it
again and it wasn't that
you know expected all of this kind of
like you know hate against the libs and
you get a little bit of that at cpac but
you know hate against this and it's
going to be super white and it's going
to be anti-gay and it's going to be this
and that
and it just wasn't it was just people
coming together
getting to know any one one another and
the the amount of actual
individualism that each person is who
they are bringing what they're bringing
to
the table was the thing that's shown
through the most and i was just
shocked i mean i went home and i had to
like just think about this i was like
this doesn't make sense it doesn't match
what i was told
about these evil conservatives these
so-called evil conservatives
and then that's you know once you start
realizing how much you're being lied to
bricks start falling out of the wall
real fast
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about academia
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our academia playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're all right
over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell